it's a sequel the movie so how did you
feel when they came to you about the
project like doing the sequel were you
excited
i was like in a dream you know because
imagine
um i started in action films i did
um desperado by the way i got distracted
because i saw a duck
that keeps coming back to my house but
let's go back to the movies enough about
the animals
um i started in action movies and i
thought maybe i could be an action star
but now they didn't really offer me a
lot of action
always like just a girl every once in a
while you know i got to
do something and i cannot believe that
at 52 i get my first
proper lead well i have to say i did one
with penelope cole bundidas that yeah
it's pretty good but yeah
you know you think that yeah that's
after a certain age everybody told me
you're gonna stop working
and uh i'm i'm i like to defy you know
all stereotypes and all uh
predisposition to things and
somehow this was a dream because at 52 i
get to be
with in like in the best possible
company ever yeah with ryan reynolds and
sam jackson
and i get to kick some butt yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help